[音楽]
[拍手]
はいここまで音楽英語と続けましたがここ
からは日本語で初めましてワールドシップ
オーケストラの
代表の野沢明夫と申します私はここ
奈良市高畑町に生まれ育ち本題で
バイオリンの演奏を学びましたが大学院で
は少し方向を変えて
芸術と社会をいかにつなぐかというアート
マネジメントを学びましたそして大学院
在学中にワールドシップオーケストラと
いう世界中の子どもたちに
初めてのオーケストラ体験を届ける
団体を作りこれまで8年間東南アジアを
中心に6か国にて数万人の子供たちに音楽
を届けてきました
この中以降は日本での演奏やワールド
シップ以外ではオペラの制作に携わるなど
しています大学までは音楽を専門に学んで
いたんですけれども当時大阪ではプロ
オーケストラへの助成金がカットされて
しまうというような動きがあったんですが
あまり変化がなかったクラシック業界を見
て日本のオーケストラの衰退を
憂いたというかこのまま音楽が死んでいく
のを見たくないと大学院ではアート
マネジメントを学びましたさて本日は
世界を響かせる試食
旅をしようというのをテーマにお話をし
ますこのテーマだけ見てもちょっとよく
わからないと思いますので
ゆっくり説明していきますので試食する
つもりで気軽に聞いてみてください
はい
突然ですが皆さん
オーケストラを生で聞いたことはあります
か生で聞いたことあるよという方挙手
オーケストラを生で聞いたことがあるかっ
た
半分ぐらいありがとうございます半分
ぐらいですね4割ぐらいですかね
ありがとうございます基本的に物事って
いうのは一度でも何々経験をしたことが
あれば何々したことがあるという風に言え
ますよね本日のトークテーマはトークは
そういうそのような
経験や行動を一度気軽にしてみませんかと
試食してみなはれというお話ですはいまず
は少し自分の仕事の話をしましょう私が
運営するワールドシップオーケストラは
途上国の子どもたちにオーケストラを届け
ていますでその際に
必ず行うのが指揮者体験です指揮者体験
この指揮者体験というのはお客さんが
オーケストラを実際に指揮してみるという
ものでたくさんのお客さんの中から2人
ほど選びますで色紙したい人って聞いた時
の反応なんですけれどもやっぱり国によっ
て様々ですやはりシャイで手が上がり
にくいのは日本ですねでフィリピンとか
だったらたくさんの子供たちが元気よく手
を挙げて指揮者の使命が
困難なほどです試食をしてみることに
躊躇のない国民性というのが現れていると
思います5年ほど前フィリピンで一般の方
の対象にしたコンサートでの指揮者体験の
際手を挙げて舞台上に来た青年にこう尋ね
ました
式は
初めてですか
青年はこう答えました指揮したことあるよ
どこでですか青年はさらに続けてこう答え
ましたここでワールドシップを指揮したん
だそう彼は2度目のチャレンジャーでした
そして最高のパフォーマンスで会場を熱狂
させました
終演後に彼と彼の母親が舞台上を訪れ
母親は嬉しそうにこう話しましたこの子は
ワールドシップのコンサートで指揮をして
以来指揮者になりたいとYouTubeで
世界中のオーケストラ動画を見ては
式の練習をしているのよとまだまだ
クラシック音楽が普及しないフィリピンで
このような青年が生まれたと聞いた時
ワールドシップの存在意義を改めて実感し
ましたまたカンボジアでも同様に音楽の目
が育っていることを実感した事例があり
ます
国が新たに作った
子どもたちのマーチングバンドを指導して
ほしいとのことで
講演を兼ねて足を運びましたカンボジアに
はASEANで
唯一プロのオーケストラがなく
オーケストラは子供たちによる
オーケストラが一つだけしかありません
つまりカンボジアの方がオーケストラを
聞く機会というのはほぼ皆無であると言え
ます
今日のトーク冒頭で皆さんにした質問を
覚えてますか生のオーケストラを聞いた
ことはありますかという質問でしたこの
質問に対してカンボジアの子どもたちは
99%ノーと答えます聞いたことはないと
答えますですがこの時の答えに私は驚き
ました多くの子供がイエスオーケストラを
聞いたことがあるというのです不思議に
思いましたがすぐにもう一つの質問を
投げかけましたじゃあワールドシップ
オーケストラを聞いたことがある人はする
と同じ
子どもたちが手を挙げてくれました
様々な地域から集まって構成された新しく
作られたマーチングバンドの子どもたちは
様々な場所で私たちの演奏を聞いてくれて
いましたそして私たちがきっかけかどうか
は分かりませんが
楽器を始めるという決意をしてそこに
集まってくれていました
ワールドシップは東南アジアにおいて学校
に赴いて全児童生徒に音楽を届けています
そういった意味でワールドシップの
アウトリーチコンサートは有無を言わさず
に試食を強いる行為ですこれは本当のこと
を言うとベストではありませんそれは何事
においても主体性を持って自ら自発的に
行うということが何かしらを経験する上で
は重要だからですしかしながら予期せず
試食をしても
オーケストラて心地いいなとかクラシッ
クってきれいだなというふうなことを
伝えることもできますそのため特に生の
オーケストラに触れる機会のない国々では
私たちの演奏には一定の意義があると思っ
ています
ワールドシップはカンボジア史上初となる
オーケストラ伴奏による本格的オペラにも
協力しましたワールドシップ設立当初から
ワールドカンボジアオペラプロジェクトの
主催者さんがカンボジアでオペラをという
風に語っていた
夢物語は数年の後には実現しましたさすが
に無理やろではなくやってみようと
チャレンジすることの意義を知りました今
では
在カンボジア大使館の方からカンボジアで
最も知名度の高いオーケストラと太鼓判を
されるに至っています
私自身自分の嗅覚で
面白そうと思うことは実際にやってみる
ように心がけてきました
中学生の頃からバイオリンで路上ライブを
してみたりスリランカに3ヶ月住んでみ
たりウーバーイーツの配達員をしたり
紅白歌合戦でラドウィンプスの後ろで演奏
したりもうやりたいなと思うことは全て
やるようにしてきましたもちろん
失敗も多々ありましたが今となっては
報道して得た
経験が生きるシーンの方が多いかなと感じ
ていますこれもある意味での試食ですね
それでは
路上ライブの話を少ししましょう皆さんは
2011年3月11日3.11のことは
覚えてますか今中学生ぐらいの方は記憶に
はないかもしれません当時私は大学生大阪
でのオペラの練習中にホールが大きく揺れ
たのを今でも鮮明に
覚えていますなぜかその日の夜はプロレス
で演奏していたんですけれども
楽屋で
凄惨な津波の映像を見たとき自分には何が
できるだろうと自分が音楽をしている意味
について考えました
翌日がオペラの講演その翌日から私は高校
時代の友人らと一緒にJR奈良駅前で
路上ライブで
義援金を集めました
自分たちにできることは音楽しかないだ
からこそそれが最善の選択かどうかを深く
考える前にまず行動に移しました初日には
なんと20万円以上の募金が集まりこれは
続けなければいけないという使命感のもと
毎日続けました毎日毎日8時間近く
演奏して
義援金は総額200万円にもなりました中
にはあまり募金してるんかと
疑う人もいましたが実際に募金証明を貼る
貼って続けることで新聞にも取り上げられ
ましたし
涙ぐみながら
支援してくださる方もたくさんいました
輪は広がり同級生に加えて高校の後輩らも
様々な楽器を持って集まってくれました
あの時も同様
路上ライブなんてと思う方もいるかもしれ
ないけれど今自分たちに何ができるだろう
と考えて
熟考するよりも先に行動をしていました一
歩踏み出すことの
意義そして人を巻き込むことの重要性を
知りましたこの話には後日談があります
半年後大学の先輩との会話の中で私の
ところにバイオリン習いたいっていう子が
来たんやけどなんで習いたいと思ったのっ
て聞いたら
奈良駅前でバイオリン弾くお兄ちゃんがい
てって言っててそれ野沢くんやんなぁと
いう風に聞かれました多分僕ですねと答え
つつ自分が路上で
演奏したことがきっかけでバイオリンに
関心を持つことができるという事実が
すごくうれしく音楽の普及活動の意義を
知りましたそしてとにかくやってみると
いうことの力を
改めて実感しました
スーパーの食料品コーナーで試食をする時
これを食べると自分の中の価値観が崩壊し
二度と他者の餃子は食べられなくなるので
はという不安が頭をよぎることはなく
美味しそう食べたいという一心で試食
トライすることができます
私が考える試食チャレンジ
経験というのもおよそこのようなものです
またクラシックは生ライブを
追求しますマイクやスピーカーを通さずに
生音を届けます
ヨーロッパでは
路上で生の楽器を見ることも多く中には
グランドピアノを転がして
持参して路上ライブする人もドイツで2回
実際に見たことがあります皆さんに最初
質問したのも生のオーケストラを聞いた
ことがありますかという質問でしたテレビ
やYouTubeではなくて生ライブの
持つ意義というのは今も昔も変わらず生
つまり本物に触れることの重要性はこれ
までもこれからも変わることはなく大きな
価値を持ちます
スーパーの試食とクラシックの演奏に共通
するのは生であるという点ですいずれも
実際の経験私が考える試食というのは生の
体験である必要があると言えます
ひょんなことが人生を変えることがあり
ます自分は大学院在学中に就活しましたが
見事全社落ち
吹っ切れて友人と現在のワールドシップを
作りました
悲観的にならずに自分が本当にしたいこと
を自分の意思で決定するそのためにもまず
はやってみるということが重要だと考えて
いますそして何かをするには続けるには
他者の力が必要であることも
忘れてはなりませんワールドシップを作る
時には当時の代表と2人で作り何重にもの
仲間たちと共に現地に音楽を届け今では
延べ1400人もの音楽家が関わってくれ
ました
人を巻き込むことで多くの人の力を得て
大きなことをなせるのだと思います
一般的に私たち日本人はチャレンジへの
抵抗があったりリスクを恐れるという傾向
があります一度何かを行うと取り返しが
つかなくなるという思いが強いのかもしれ
ませんしかし実際には思ったよりも人生は
何とでもなるし取り返しもつくと自分は
考えてます
大学の学部の決定や
就活で自分がしたいことが見つからないと
いう方も多いようです
趣味がない何が好きかわからないそんな人
ほど試食することを恐れず自分の人生その
もので
遊んで楽しんでみてほしいと思います
試食したからそれを趣味にしなければなら
ないということはなく自分の本当に愛せる
ものを愛し続ければいいと思います
好きこそものの上手なれ好きでなければ
続かないし苦しみながら何かを続ける必要
はないと思いますもちろん
努力は時には必要ですが好きなものに
費やす努力は思ったよりも苦痛ではあり
ません
さてここまで話したことをまとめてみ
ましょう
指揮者体験をきっかけに指揮者に憧れた
フィリピンの青年ワールドシップをの演奏
を聞いたことのあるカンボジアの子供たち
路上ライブを聞いて
楽器を始めた少年そしてまあ楽しそうだ
からやってみようと友人と作った
オーケストラ彼らそして私に共通している
のは一度の実体験試食や行動をきっかけに
何かしらの変化があったという点です
一歩踏み出す勇気やチャレンジする勇気を
持つことそれは生半可なことではありませ
ん現に自分にはそのような勇気はありませ
ん実際私はレストランの予約の電話もかけ
られません
今回皆さんにお話しした世界を響かせる
試食をしよう旅をしよう試食をするのに
大きな勇気はいりません
友達や親御さんと2人で誰かと一緒にせー
ので試食コーナーに足を踏み出すように
気軽に様々な世界を見て聞いて飛び込んで
みてはいかがでしょうか
自分が幼少期より愛してきた音楽大学に
入ってプロのオーケストラに入るという夢
は形を変えて東南アジアの子供たちに音楽
を届けていますが何か一つのことに
取り組んでもその答えや目的地というのは
一通りではなくたくさんの分岐点があって
しかるべきだしその広がりこそが多くの
人々に音楽を届けるきっかけにもなると
考えています
夢を
諦めるということは
悔しかったり苦しいかもしれませんしかし
夢が
編成をたどって新たな夢になることを
恐れないことも大切です
最後にくだらない情報を一つ実は私も何か
試食
挑戦しなければと2週間前からダイエット
を始めましたこれが1月前の写真ですね
そして今この時よりも8km
痩せましたあまり見た目は変わりませんよ
ねでも8kg痩せましたはい
試食行動が変化をもたらすというこれ以上
なく分かりやすい事例ですね
まずは試食試食してみなはれそしてあなた
が愛すべき経験や物事に出会ったならば
世界中の人に試食してもらいましょう
あなたの一度の試食が世界を響かせ結果的
に社会そのものを変えてしまうかもしれ
ませんご清聴ありがとうございました天気
予想マーチ
[拍手]